can we just skip to the part where I
thrash you all he doesn't know in a
world of ordinary men I am a Wonder
Woman I kind of like that no kidding
when we heard there was a break-in at
the White House who expected the invader
to employ
[Music]
clearing the path be there soon
I heard you could use some pest control
you'll have to get through the Justice
League I accept your challenge thanks
Diana
these men are your friends up more like
sidekicks mother follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
Gotham's most notorious criminal may be
an alien science experiment right now
justice served
[Music]
Wonder Woman what an honor
luckily I dressed for the occasion your
battle suit may be invulnerable you are
thirsty that's right
the which is bad I still need more food
- no mere man can defy talent oh no man
does but Wonder Woman dares to do
anything
[Music]
Wonder Woman are you okay
hardly I'm tight in my own laughs though
I didn't get beat any cannoli for
dessert and I still haven't gotten that
Kip I must have been hit harder than I
thought
[Music]
[Applause]